[Music]
let's go to melissa in salt lake city
hey melissa what's going on
hi john how are you i'm fantastic how
about you
i'm doing well thank you awesome so
what's up how can i help
so
i would love to ask you a question and
then i'd love to give you a little bit
of context so cool do me a favor talk
talk right into the phone i'll make sure
i don't miss this right
right in the phone is that better
perfect yes okay
i am dealing with some feelings of
how do i help with these feelings like i
am the thriving force
behind my marriage and my family
so i have a wonderful husband he is a
great dad he provides for our family
pitches in
um he's had a fairly smooth life and
it's been pretty mapped out for him and
he's just kind of checked things off
um
when it comes to goals when it comes to
building relationships when it comes to
personal and improvement these are not
things that cross his mind
and
i feel like especially when it comes to
wanting my kids to have
strong healthy relationships with him
i feel like i'm the one that's leading
i'm directing i'm pushing it turns into
what feels like nagging
feels like not having a t
and
i just
i get exhausted of the feeling of
feeling like i have to take care of
everyone and everything
i don't i want to have i don't want to
feel like i'm fooling relationships
because that
inauthenticity however you say that word
is will be felt i don't know if that
makes sense right
um i i guess the best way for me to
describe it is that he's the boat
and he's just cruising along through
life on the water and i am the propeller
and i am spinning like crazy
to get forward momentum
and
it's just unseen so
i i
would love your thoughts and opinions
but i also feel a little bit
silly
colin asked me about this because he is
such a wonderful man and he's
when i've listened to your show before
and the crisis that people have in their
lives it just makes me feel a little
i don't know bashful i guess
i don't think that at all i i'm grateful
that yeah i'm grateful that you called
um
everybody's got holes in their boat
to use your analogy some of them are
huge
some of them are small
but the boat is filling up with water
yeah and
sometimes when there's a giant hole in
the boat it's actually better because
you got to deal with it right now
what you're describing is the birthplace
of resentment and you've heard me say
over and over that's the end of
everything
or more importantly
um or more negatively however whatever
word you want to use
this is how you run into somebody at
work and they're a super go-getter
and they're kind of funny
and
they
laugh when you make a joke and you all
go ahead and grab lunch together and
suddenly two years down the road you
find yourself in a position like oh no
right yeah that's where this starts
right here great guy awesome
wouldn't even occur to him to cheat on
anybody it's not going to hurt him to do
anything because he's just doing what he
does right
yeah
and am i on the am i
am on the right track
yes yeah okay so
um
how long have you all been married
13 years
see you're right there okay
how many how old are your kids
the oldest is 11 you're just two we have
four of them
eleven to two
uh-huh so you've been pregnant for a
decade
exactly yes i've had a decade of
pregnancy and childbirth exactly wow
okay
um
and no more four and no more is our
motto
our season has passed
[Laughter]
four no more ours was two and i'm done
with you james uh you're four no more
two
um
have you have you sat down and told him
this stuff
i have many times talk to me about what
that's like
let me let me back it up let's don't
even do that question yet where do you
want to go
where do i want to go
because here's what i here's what i'm
afraid is happening
and
i've got no context for this call i'm
just i've heard your voice a thousand
times and tell you you say dylan you're
wrong you're crazy on this one
okay
he's his life is exactly how he drew it
up
he has an incredible wife he's got four
healthy wonderful kids he's got an 11
year old a two-year-old and everyone in
between he's got a job he goes to and he
comes home the house is there things are
just rocking and rolling
my fear is you just want to go for the
sake of going
you don't even know where you just want
to go
and
it's that pent-up energy that's going to
get everybody in trouble because it's
got it's not directed anywhere does that
make sense
yeah
so are you just feeling this this
13-year same guy you got four kids and
you're missing romance and excitement
and the mystery in the ah
is that what it
is definitely ahead of that okay so what
else is it
yeah i think it's also just feeling like
i
i i see improvements to making myself
and i see improvements and i i see
things that i that i value i value
having ships with little kids and
um
and putting in the effort
to have that kind of relationship and to
and to practice what i preach like to
hey you're um your phone call your
phone's breaking up can you go to places
this is super important can you place we
get good signal all right no you're good
is that okay great perfect much much
better
okay i guess i'm just kind of
there is a little bit of like this
stagnant i guess that i can feel of just
like okay i just need something i just
need a little spark i need just a little
something but then there's also the
feeling of i have these values that i
try to show in my actions of valuing my
kids and valuing
personal improvement through my health
and through you know physical activities
and
putting in effort and i value
having a relationship with him and the
effort feels so one-sided
okay is this covert for he's gained a
lot of weight you're not attracted to
him anymore
oh no absolutely not okay if anything
i've done that
so
what what is
get to the root like there's something
you're you're so kind
and you're so diplomatic get to the root
oh gosh
have you ever cheated on him
no
never are you thinking about it
no are you bored to death
no
are you scared about tomorrow what i
mean where what what is it
i think it's just feeling like i'm the
only one that's putting any effort in
this relationship
it's feeling like what's the effort
towards
because i keep hearing conversations
about energy
yeah the effort is probably towards
him having a relationship with me
feeling like i have to be the one that
instigates everything i have to
instigate like hey it's been a while
since we've been on a date or hey it's
been a while since you've had one-on-one
time with each of the kids and hey maybe
we should like plan a family trip to
spend time with each other and hey maybe
we should
spend less time on our phone so that our
kids can see our eyes when we're around
them and
hey let's maybe and it's just like this
constant initiation that i have to put
forth
where i almost feel like this i don't
know if it's discontent or if it's just
this drive to
improve no you're dealing with it you
relax listen melissa that's what i was
looking for
i your whole yo when you listen to this
call go back and listen
that's the voice i was looking for
that's the voice of a woman who's
married to a depressed man
a man who's checked out
a man who doesn't feel like he's got a
purpose in his own house
yeah he's got no mission in his house
he's got a wife that runs everything
that tells everybody where they need to
be the picture
y'all a family that gets like family
photos
uh every once in a while yeah when we
have a new kid
see and do you tell everyone where
they're going to stand
um
what they're going to wear and exactly
right
yeah yeah
so what you are doing is you have a very
clear picture of what family is what
life is what husband looks like what
kids are going to look like how they're
going to talk how they're going to act
how much sex we're going to have what
our bodies are going to look like you've
got very clear pictures
yeah and for 13 years plus however many
years you dated this guy
you've just been the picture person
yeah
and he hasn't
for
a decade and a half now
he's just going along with your photo
yeah
and over time he's checked out
completely
yeah he's out and so
he's getting his needs met through a
phone or through his work relationships
or through his girlfriend and i'm being
provocative if you're on purpose i'm not
saying
but yeah he's getting his needs met
somewhere else because the needs at his
home are being met by you
right and then the only way you think
you can rattle the cage
is complaining nagging blaming
threatening right
these
these things that you feel like you're
rattling the cage and all they do to
somebody who's checked out
is it further reinforces they made the
right decision to be unplugged
and the difference being what is caring
and listening and contributing support
what is that what does that look like
and so you said you've talked to him a
lot about it
put me in the seat you guys are out on a
marriage retreat just you two y'all took
one together
and you sit down with him and don't say
hey
i need somebody who's going to do this i
want this i want this if you ask him
how's your life
do you still like me
do you like her kids
what would his answer to those questions
be
it would be yes
but
he probably would have never thought
about it before i asked
and so what he needs to know is that
that's an expectation i need you to
think about these things
does he know that
yeah that's the perpetual argument we
have
and how is that an argument
like so for instance here's what i'm
getting at i was able i'm able to go to
bed with their dishes in the zinc i just
am it's a spiritual gift whatever i can
just go to bed
uh my wife cannot right they need to be
the the place needs to be and i could
walk past them
and it wasn't until she was able to say
i need you to come see this this weighs
on my heart that i went oh gosh well
then i can just help with that like that
does that make sense it was i just
wasn't seeing it
now that you have said this matters to
me and should you have to tell a dad to
put his phone down no that's the world
worker so you did that right
yeah
he's checked out and so when you say i
need you to plug back in i need your
phone to go in a drawer because right
now your kids believe you love that
little digital box more than them what
does he say
it happens he's willing
and it just doesn't last
have you told
him here is my here is my either-or
statement
either you put your phone away and
connect with your kids or
i'm gonna take them to mother and
father's house we're gonna get out of
here
have you done that
no
because you keep telling me he's a great
wonderful awesome wonderful guy and then
you told me the things he's not involved
with and that doesn't say great and
awesome and wonderful
right
if you mean great and awesome and
wonderful because he's peaceful and
doesn't hit anybody who doesn't yell at
anybody
that's that's the basics you're not
supposed to hit or yell or scream
right
yeah that doesn't make you wonderful
that's baseline
wait
why won't you know him why won't he
engage yeah why is he scared of you is
he annoyed by you is he not attracted to
you what's the deal
i think you know what is it i think i
think it's just because it's easier
it's easier just to let me take care of
everything
do you let him take care of things
letting me take care of him i know but
do you let him
do you let him choose vacations do you
let him choose dinner places when you
say i want to get photos taken we're all
going to wear our white little sailor
outfits and he says can we just wear a
regular clothes do you go that's cool or
do you say no this is what we're wearing
if he put the effort into thinking about
a vacation
and to thinking about dinner places i
asked yes i would let him why doesn't he
date his wife anymore that's my
question because it takes effort it
can't it can't be that because he had a
lot of effort when he chased you down is
that right
no
okay then so now you're mad that he's
six foot tall and you married a six foot
tall guy
yeah
like it sounds like he didn't trick you
no
it sounds like you hoped this would just
quote unquote work itself out
or somehow by osmosis he would just
transform into the into the guy that you
so badly want him to be
i just
yeah
probably
i think i think before just it was just
easier it was easier you know i could go
on for
six five six seven years and and be okay
taking care of everything and then
probably the last two years has kind of
whacked me over the head with a bat and
all of a sudden it was like i i don't
have it anymore
to take care of everything
anymore yeah and so
i need to feel like i'm not i'm the only
one
i need to feel like i'm not the only one
putting in the effort i'm not the only
one that cares about what the
relationships with our kids looks like
i'm not the only one that cares about
the relationship in our marriage and
what it looks like so i'm gonna break
your heart melissa okay
damn kid don't do that no i'm just
kidding go ahead
it's not gonna change
yeah
it's not
yeah
this is who you married and you've done
that for 15 years now do i think he
could change oh my gosh absolutely he
could
yeah absolutely good
but your conversations you're you're
nagging you're threatening
your um complaining it's not it's not
doing anything
and so i think we're at a moment now in
your family's history where you've got
to decide what's the next move for you
have you gone to see somebody by
yourself just to talk through this
yes i've been seeing somebody for
postpartum depression for the last year
or so and this has come up and we have
discussed this yes and what did they say
to do
a little bit of the same thing of of
you can't
you can't control the relationships that
he has with the kids
that's not your place
you know it's just you just can't i
can't control because if i
force relationships or if i force it the
kids would
potentially get old enough and will say
well that dad didn't really want to that
was mom forcing him well and beyond that
you're going to be exhausted and
heartbroken the whole the whole time
right because none of it will be real
yeah
right so here's what i want you to do
at the end of the day it's the old
dr henry cloud quote that i love which
is he's gonna have to get some problems
and he doesn't have any
there is no reason in his life other
than integrity and character which he
doesn't have
to get involved with this kid's life
to do the hard crazy work of
having four kids in 10 years and
rediscovering who his wife is re-dating
her
deciding i'm gonna level into this
family support this family not just
financially but
emotionally
psychologically spiritual all those
things right i'm gonna be connected in
this thing
he's gonna have to get some problems and
he's never had him he's never had to he
doesn't even know what that is
i want you to get a book by dr henry
cloud called necessary endings
okay
and i'm not telling you to end your
marriage in any way shape form or
fashion
yeah i'm telling you you are making
yourself clinically insane by trying to
close the gap
that has always been there
yeah does that make sense
absolutely and at the end of the day
your choices are i'm gonna love
this i'm gonna love those kids like
they've never been loved before ever
and i'm not gonna i can't get into his
i'm gonna have to accept how he's chosen
to parent
or
you're gonna have to go do something
else
yeah does that make sense yep but just
yelling into the grand canyon isn't
solving that problem
there's either acceptance of it
and you have to work for the rest of
your
kids lives to not fall into resentment
or you're gonna have to sit down with
your husband and say here's my or what
statement you're gonna get involved
you're gonna put the phone away
you're gonna we're gonna learn how to
love each other again we're gonna start
practicing desire we're gonna go to
marriage retreats we're gonna go to
marriage counseling we're gonna go back
and remember what's like to love each
other and i'm not carrying the weight of
this family anymore
we are going to carry the weight of this
family and i'm asking you to learn a
whole new skill set and i've seen it
happen over and over and over again i
know he can if he wants to here's where
this sucks though
is it's a risk because he might look at
you and say no
yeah right and in fact in many ways he
has right
yeah because you've asked him over and
over and over and over
is that fair
yep
no i totally get it sorry you hit the
nail on the head when you talk about
being connected not just financially
because we've had that conversation of
you are more than a paycheck that puts a
roof over our head
and and and
you've got to ask yourself have i
treated him like anything other than a
paycheck
does his opinions matter in this house
and so maybe you all go out and you have
a retreat and say i'm looking down the
road we have a two-year-old and 11 year
old we've got eight years left
for our oldest one to be here at our
home we have 16 years left for our
youngest one to be in our home
i want to we're done now for we're for
and out i want to build what i want to
sit down and map out what the next 10
years is going to be and i'm done
driving
i've driven for 15 years i'm out i'm not
driving anymore i'm handing you the keys
and here's what that looks like in my
head i want to hear what it looks like
in your head in my head it looks like no
phones in my head it looks like
um
you and i go on dates every single week
so our kids can look like we can have a
picture of what romance actually looks
like
we're gonna hug and we're gonna kiss
every morning and at night ooh
in front of the kids so they see what
that looks like
we're gonna argue and fall back in love
we're gonna have two vacations a year
and you're gonna plan one of them alone
and we're gonna go
and so on
you need to be very clear with what you
are expecting the driver of this car to
look like
but he needs to know that have it very
clear and you tell him i will support
you i will love you i will go to these
things with you as you learn these new
schools but i'm gonna be involved with
you
but we're gonna have to build this thing
up from the floor up
and all of this all of this melissa is a
risk
because he may just say no
but you deserve it and your kids deserve
it
thanks for that call i want to know how
that
conversation that breakfast you'll take
that half day retreat you take on a
saturday i don't know what that's like
give us a call back and let me know how
that goes and by the way if he wants to
call the show i would love love love to
talk to that dude i'd love to all right
thank you so much for the call